В ефірі новини дня «heute» з Мітрі Зіріним.
Добрий вечір всім.
Сьогодні у світі спорту багато нового.
Чи не так, Крістін?
Так, зокрема у Мюнхені.
Безліч цікавого й на Чемпіонаті Футбольної ліги.
Та спершу до вашої уваги теми сьогоднішнього випуску.
Суперечливі плани організації податків Лінднера.
З огляду на високий рівень інфляції міністр фінансів Німеччини
планує змінити розрахування податкової ставки
та подолати так звану холодну прогресію.
Обмін електроенергії на газ.
Через недостатню роботу французьких АЕС
країна імпортує німецьку електроенергію,
а взимку пропонує експортувати газ.
Найкращий з нас.
Зворушливе прощання
Гамбурга та збірної Німеччини з футболу з Уве Зеелером.
Сьогодні німці дедалі менше можуть
купити за ті самі гроші, ніж раніше.
І хоча рівень інфляції в липні дещо знизився,
зараз він закріпився на позначці 7,5%.
Тож сьогодні вранці всі з нетерпінням чекали на виступ
міністра фінансів Крістіана Лінднера, який мав поділитися
своїм планом щодо податкових пільг.
Він планує компенсувати наслідки
так званої холодної прогресії.
Давайте спершу детально розглянемо це поняття.
У Німеччині обсяг доходів визначає
рівень податків.
Якщо збільшується дохід - зростають і податки.
Інфляція може призвести до того,
що навіть попри збільшення зарплати -
грошей у гаманці буде менше.
Брітта Бухгольц знає, як Крістіан Лінднер
планує розв'язувати проблему.
Міністр запрошує журналістів
до саду Федерального міністерства фінансів.
Новий фон для його ідеї.
Він хоче організувати податкову
систему з урахуванням інфляції.
Йдеться про 10 млрд євро.
Ми хочемо запобігти підвищенню податків.
Тут йдеться  не про пільги для полегшення становища.
А про спробу вберегти людей від його критичного погіршення.
Ще ніколи так терміново не треба було помʼякшувати
наслідки холодної прогресії, ніж зараз.
Лінднер планує змінити нарахування податків.
Тепер рівень доходів,
який не обкладається податками, має зрости.
Верхня податкова ставка також.
І хоча партія SPD критикує такий план,
все ж вона відкрита до комунікації.
Добре, що Лінднер це зробив.
Важливо, що він показав: ми хочемо встановити
контроль над процесами у фінансовій галузі.
SPD вважає за потрібне брати до уваги тих,
хто найбільше постраждав від актуальної кризи.
А це ﻿люди з малим і середнім доходом.
Зокрема,  ми плануємо обговорити це з міністром фінансів.
Такий план радше допоможе
людям з низьким доходом, ніж з високим.
На абсолютних показниках це виглядатиме так.
Громадяни з оподаткованим доходом сумою 20 000 євро
наступного року платитимуть на 115 євро менше податку.
Якщо дохід становить 60 000 євро, то на 471 євро.
Люди з ще вищим рівнем доходу платитимуть
на 479 євро менше.
Також з 2023 року заплановано підвищити допомогу
на двох перших дітей
на вісім євро на місяць, на третю дитину - на два євро.
Податковий кредит на дітей
також поступово підвищуватиметься.
Проте критики наполягають на прямій допомозі людям
з низьким доходом. Тут партії Зелених і Лівих погоджуються.
За планом Лінднера люди з більшим доходом, зрештою
отримуватимуть також більше.
На нашу думку, це не справедливо.
Це сумнівна пропозиція.
За якої виграють багаті, й програють бідні.
70% населення не отримають від такої «допомоги» або нічого,
або дуже мало.
Лінднер стверджує,
що завдяки його концепту можна буде допомогти
48 млн громадян.
Світлофорна коаліція поки
не пояснює, як саме цього досягти.
Вітаємо у студії Тео Коля,
який проаналізує актуальну ситуацію.
Плани Лінднера критикує не лише опозиція,
але й прибічники.
Що зрештою вийде втілити?
Загалом я вважаю, що реалізується більшість планів.
Адже високий рівень інфляції не має
ще більше зашкодити громадянам.
Лінднер зробив внутрішньокоаліційну мирну пропозицію,
за якої люди з високим рівнем доходів не отримають допомогу.
Насправді запитання в тому,
як надалі допомагати населенню.
Податок на дохід це одне, а якщо основним навантаженням
стануть непрямі податки.
Як-от податок на додану вартість.
А він з огляду на підвищення цін
ускладнить життя всім, насамперед людям з низьким доходом.
А з жовтня треба буде ще й оплачувати платіжки за газ.
Попереду на світлофорну коаліцію чекають численні дискусії.
Чи треба перерозподілити
прибуток енергетичних компаній?
Чи варто зупинити дію принципу «боргового гальма»?
Як бути далі з проїзним за дев'ять євро чи АЕС?
Проблеми коаліції зараз ще більше загострилися.
Тож їхнє вирішення має пришвидшитися.
Дякую.
З нами в студії був Тео Коль наживо з Берліна.
Нас спіткала найбільша енергетична криза
за останні декілька десятиліть.
Один із найстабільніших
постачальників електроенергії для Німеччини
ледь вирішує свої проблеми.
Йдеться про Францію. І хоча у країні
налічується 56 ядерних реакторів,
задовольняти власні потреби наразі вона не може.
А все тому, що через тривалі ремонтні роботи
експлуатуються лише 27 із них.
Тепер французам потрібна електроенергія з Німеччини,
ба більше, сильна посуха ускладнює роботу АЕС.
Репортаж Томаса Вальде.
Через спеку і посуху температура води у річці
Гаронна, що на південному заході Франції,
піднялася до +28°C.
Це проблематично для АЕС, що розташована у
муніципалітеті Гольфеш.
Адже її реактори охолоджуються водою з Гаронни.
А зараз вода після «охолодження» тепліша, ніж допускається.
Екологи засуджують це.
Вода температурою більш як +30°C
містить менше кисню.
А рибам, як і нам, потрібен кисень.
Попри спеку та низький рівень води у річці,
п'ять атомних електростанцій у Франції отримали
спеціальний дозвіл, щоб продовжити функціонування
та забезпечувати країну електроенергією.
Якої зараз дуже не вистачає.
А все тому, що внаслідок пошкодження корозією
та тривалих ремонтних робіт
половина французьких АЕС не функціонують.
Французам не пояснюють,
що на них чекатиме взимку.
Політики продовжують леліяти міф про атомну енергетику,
яка врятує Францію.
Уряд оголосив будування 14 нових реакторів.
Цього вистачить ненадовго.
Замість звичних 70% електроенергії,
АЕС виробляє лише 58%.
Замість експорту електроенергії, Франція змушена її імпортувати.
Також з Німеччини.
Ми хочемо захистити економіку.
Хочемо, щоб Німеччина могла зараз, коли нам потрібно,
забезпечити нас електроенергією.
А ми натомість допоможемо Німеччині
з газом, коли він буде необхідний.
Франція може постачати його у Німеччину
терміналами зрідженого газу.
Французький газ в обмін на німецьку електроенергію.
Для реалізації цього плану
французи закликають німців
продовжити експлуатацію АЕС.
Іспанія також хоче заощаджувати енергію.
Віднині там функціонує комплексний план,
щоб зменшити залежність Європи від російського газу.
Громадські будівлі, комерційні приміщення,
готелі й залізничні станції дозволено охолоджувати до +27°C.
Бари й ресторани - до +25°C.
Взимку внутрішні приміщення дозволено обігрівати
на максимум +19°C.
А після 10 вечора слід вимикати освітлення вітрин,
монументів та порожніх офісних приміщень.
Вчора прогриміло кілька вибухів на російській військовій базі
на анексованому півострові Крим.
Як наслідок - на території оголошено надзвичайний стан.
Тож постає питання: чи можна вважати це нападом?
Москва заперечує та повідомляє про аварію.
Президент України Зеленський у своєму відеозверненні
говорить про те,
що Російська війна почалася з Криму.
Тож там вона і завершиться. Звільненням півострова.
Якщо ж цю атаку здійснили ЗСУ, тоді це перший військовий
напад на військові обʼєкти в Криму.
Який розташований на відстані
близько 200 км від лінії фронту.
Рік тому рух «Талібан» захопив владу в Афганістані.
За цей час ісламісти звели нанівець прогрес у питаннях
освіти та рівноправʼя.
Для репортажу Катрін Айгендорф
та Себастіан Ем зустріли молодих дівчат та жінок,
життя яких радикально змінилося
після захоплення влади рухом «Талібан».
Детальніше у репортажі.
Ми в підпільній школі десь в Афганістані.
Де саме, сказати не можемо - занадто небезпечно.
«Талібан» погрожує непосильними штрафами.
Цей урок заборонений в Афганістані.
Дівчатам після шостого класу,
за словами талібів, заборонено ходити до школи.
Попри заборону 17-річна Захра сьогодні також тут.
Вона хоче стати лікаркою.
Чому ми не можемо закінчити школу?
Яка різниця між дівчатами і хлопцями?
Закіні також лише 17.
Донедавна вона ще ходила до школи,
а тепер ця дівчина - вчитель. Вона побудувала все з нуля:
знайшла клас для 50 учнів і учениць, організувала книги,
склала навчальний план.
Вона робить все добровільно, грошей не заробляє.
* оплески *
Тут кожен хоче вивчати англійську мову, щоб виїхати за кордон.
Після цього вони хочуть повернутися до Афганістану,
щоб в мирі відбудувати нашу країну.
Про заборону школи для дівчат
сперечаються між собою навіть таліби.
В інтерв'ю ZDF Міністерствопоширення моралі
та запобігання порокам пообіцяло,
що функціонуватимуть як жіночі школи до шостого класу,
так і університети.
Не можна переходити з шостого класу
відразу в університет.
Тому ми плануємо відкрити школи
для дівчат старшого віку.
Таліби вже давно обіцяють реформувати
систему освіти.
Проте в цій підпільній школі таким обіцянкам не вірять.
Закіна продовжує таємно проводити уроки.
По шість годин щодня.
Репортаж про «Прихований бік Афганістану»
дивіться сьогодні о 22:15 на каналі ZDF.
Матеріал вже доступний в нашій медіатеці.
Близько два з половиною мільйони учнів
у Північному Рейні-Вестфалії
сьогодні знову повернулися за парти.
Одразу після виходу дітей на навчання розпочалися й
дискусії щодо необхідності антиковідних заходів безпеки.
Варто носити маски чи ні?
Потрібно робити тести чи ні?
Міністерка освіти та наукових досліджень
Беттіна Старк-Ватцінгер
виключає можливість повного закриття шкіл.
Детальніше про початок нового навчального
року розповість Пітер Бемер.
У Північному Рейні-Вестфалії розпочався новий
навчальний рік.
Ми завітали до середньої школи
імені Вернера фон Сіменса в Дюссельдорфі.
Сьогодні перше за розкладом у 7-А
тестування на COVID-19.
Добровільне, ніякого примусу.
Ми пропонуємо вам зробити тест на коронавірус.
Тобто ви можете перевіритися,
але не зобов'язані.
Лише третина класу зголосилася здати тест.
Я не роблю тест,
тому що я перевіряюся вдома
майже щовихідних.
Я просто хотіла перевірити,
чи не захворіла на канікулах.
Якщо я інфікована, не хочу, щоб мої
однокласники підхопили вірус від мене.
Я досить часто тестувався протягом літніх канікул.
Тому сьогодні вирішив, що досить з мене тестів.
Кожен несе особисту відповідальність,
у Північному Рейні-Вестфалії всі тестування добровільні.
Проте маски на уроках одягають усі.
Кожен учень може зробити п'ять тестів на місяць,
наприклад, якщо він відчув підозрілі
симптоми і хоче перевірити, чи не захворів.
Але класний керівник має дещо
консервативніший погляд щодо цього.
Я б зробила тестування обов'язковим,
необхідно діяти згідно з чіткими інструкціями,
адже це досить непросте рішення для дитини,
тестуватися чи ні.
Навіщо мені це робити або навпаки,
чому від тесту варто відмовитися?
Що про це скажуть інші дітлахи?
Обов'язковий масковий режим
можуть запровадити лише
у зв'язку з суттєвим збільшенням випадків інфікування,
що ставитиме під загрозу стаціонарне навчання.
Тому більшість жителів Північного Рейну-Вестфалії
та інших федеральних земель вважають,
що школи мають працювати у звичайному офлайн-режимі.
Це справжній виклик для
педагогічного колективу.
Якщо п'ять-шість вчителів захворіють,
це означатиме величезну
кількість додаткової роботи для їхніх колег.
Це фактично руйнує наявний навчальний план.
Почнеться справжня плутанина.
Ми вже зафіксували сім-вісім-дев'ять-десять
подібних випадків,
але всьому є межа.
Третій рік коронавірусу.
Директорка розповіла, що навіть взимку класи
продовжуватимуть провітрювати.
На Південному Заході Франції вже два
тижні вирує страшна пожежа, тримаючи
місцевих жителів у постійній напрузі.
Одну з них ніяк не вдається взяти під контроль,
осередки вогню виникають знову і знову.
У лісистій місцевості на південь від Бордо
в зону ризику потрапило відразу три громади.
Майже 4 000 осіб довелося евакуювати,
16 будинків згоріло вщент.
Нова хвиля спеки суттєво
ускладнює роботу пожежників.
До неділі температура в регіоні
досягне близько 40°C.
Сьогодні відбулося прощання з легендою
світового футболу, бізнесменом та філантропом
Уве Зеелером.
Більш як десять років він грав за рідний Гамбург,
став президентом клубу та
почесним громадянином міста Гамбурга.
Не менш яскравим був і шлях Зеелера
в національній збірній.
«Наш Уве» пішов з життя наприкінці липня
у віці 85 років.
Сьогодні в Гамбурзі відбулося прощання
з легендарним нападником.
Більше розповість Гомейра Райн.
Скільки разів на цьому стадіоні
захоплено скандували ім'я Уве Зеелера?
Сьогодні ж, у день прощання з легендарним футболістом,,
на трибунах «Фолькспаркштадіон» поважлива тиша.
Зірковий піаніст Йога Вендт і Гамбурзький хор моряків
відкрили урочисту церемонію прощання
гімном Гамбурга «Hammonia».
Серед почесних гостей церемонії був і
президент Футбольного союзу Німеччини Бернд Ноєндорф.
У своїй зворушливій промові він згадав
Уве Зеелера як справді непересічну особистість.
Уве Зеелер не здобув визначних титулів
у формі національної збірної.
Але правда в тому, що
Уве Зеелер не потребував ніяких титулів
для того, щоб стати нашим кумиром номер один.
На прохання вдови Уве Зеелера Ілки
честь виголосити останню прощальну промову
надали давньому другу сім'ї Зеелер актору Оллі Діттріху.
Коли я дізнався про смерть Уве,
я ніби повернувся в страшний 2014 -
рік, коли одне за одним пішли з життя мої батьки.
В голові крутилася лише одна думка:
«Тепер ти залишився зовсім сам».
Серед близько 5 000 гостей було багато зірок
спорту та шоубізнесу, а також політичних діячів.
Канцлер Олаф Шольц теж був присутнім
на церемонії прощання.
Тут, на своїй батьківщині, у Гамбурзі,
Уве Зеелер ніколи не буде забутим.
Його пам'ятатимуть як блискучого спортсмена,
гідного громадянина та порядну людину.
За 790 км на схід від батьківщини Уве Зеелера незабаром
розпочнеться важлива спортивна подія, чи не так, Крістін?
Суперподія! До того ж відбуватиметься вона тут вже вдруге.
Через чотири роки після успішної
прем'єри в Глазго та Берліні
цьогоріч дев'ять турнірів Мультиспортивного чемпіонату
Європи пройдуть саме в Мюнхені, столиці Баварії.
Рівно через 50 рокі після Чемпіонату
1972-го, який теж приймав Мюнхен.
«Повернення на дахи» - саме такий слоган цьогорічного
Чемпіонату, який триматиме в Мюнхені найближчі 11 днів.
4 700 кращих спортсменів Європи
змагатимуться в дев'яти видах спорту.
Для колишнього футболіста, а зараз
успішного музиканта Marteria,
який виступить на церемонії відкриття,
цьогорічний Чемпіонат особливий.
Я думаю, що це справді знакова подія.
Мене дуже тішить, що нарешті більше уваги отримають
і інші види спорту, не лише футбол, адже вони варті цього.
Останніми тижнями
я познайомився з кількома спортсменами.
Тому я щасливий
бути частиною такого грандіозного дійства.
З німецької збірної найбільші шанси на перемогу
має Себастьян Брендель,
який минулого тижня здобув
титул чемпіона світу з веслування на каное.
Саме Брендель із Тімом Гекером -
головні претенденти на перемогу.
Ще однією фавориткою є німецька легкоатлетка, яка
спеціалізується у стрибках у довжину, Малайка Мігамбо.
Наразі не відомо, чи встигне вона повернутися у форму
після інфікування на коронавірус.
У будь-якому разі Мюнхен готовий дивувати
та перемагати, як і в далекому 1872-му.
З нами на зв'язку прямісінько з Олімпійського парку
Штефан Ляйферт.
Штефане, чого очікує Мюнхен
від Чемпіонату Європи?
Для Мюнхена це справді історичний момент.
Грандіозній церемонії відкриття, яка триває в ці хвилини
в ущент заповненому Олімпійському
парку передували три роки ретельної підготовки.
Організатори підійшли до підготовки заходу з ентузіазмом,
щоб перекреслити сумний досвід Чемпіонату 1972-го,
було вирішено створити абсолютно автентичний
сучасний спортивний захід,
який базується на
принципах сталого розвитку та компактності.
Сталість полягає у відмові від додаткових новобудов.
Змагання проходитимуть на стадіонах 70-х років.
А принцип компактності полягає в зручному розташуванні -
усі змагання відбуватимуться в центрі міста.
Навіть пляжний волейбол.
Квитки можна придбати за цілком доступними цінами -
близько 10-20 євро.
А відвідування деяких ігор та заходів
взагалі безкоштовне.
Однак є й суттєва проблема - недостатній розголос.
Багато жителів Мюнхена досі не знають про подію,
яка проходитиме в їхньому місті наступні 11 днів.
В касах лишається багато квитків.
Організатори дуже сподіваються, що вже
завтра ситуація зміниться.
Вони прагнуть пробудити цікавість народу до спорту,
а, можливо, і жагу до проведення повноцінних
Олімпійських ігор у недалекому майбутньому.
Дякуємо, Штефане.
А ми триматимемо вас у курсі подій Чемпіонату.
Отже, в Мюнхені стає гаряче!
Пряму трансляцію церемонії відкриття переглядайте
вже о 20:00 на sportstudio.de або в медіатеці ZDF.
Чемпіонат світу з футболу розпочнеться на день раніше,
вже 20 листопада,
на прохання країни, які прийматиме Чемпіонат - Катару.
Він зустрінеться в першій традиційній грі з Еквадором.
Офіційного рішення FIFA ще немає,
проте запит Катару, найімовірніше, схвалять.
Майже через три місяці після
перемоги в Лізі Європи «Айнтрахт» змагатиметься
за Суперкубок УЄФА з переможцем
Ліги чемпіонів «Реал Мадридом».
Фанати обох команд вже прибули до Гельсінкі,
де чудово проводять час.
Більше тисячі футбольних фанів із Франкфурта
прибуло, щоб вболівати за свою команду.
Не пропустіть початок матчу о 21:00.
Вболіваємо за наших!
Чекаємо на видовищну гру!
Дякуємо, Крістін.
Залишилося оголосити виграшні лотерейні номери:
10, 18, 22, 24, 26, 27 та суперчисло 2.
Більше виграшних номерів ви знайдете на сайті lotto.zdf.de
або в текстовій версії нашої програми на сторінці 557.
Коротко про погоду: спека та посуха тривають.
Детальніше розповість Озден Терлі.
О 21:45 дивіться новий випуск «heute journal»
з Марієттою Сломкою, яка підготувала для вас багато цікавого,
зокрема, інтерв’ю з міністром фінансів Лінднером.
А ми з командою «heute 19» дякуємо вам за перегляд
та бажаємо приємного вечора.
Завтра для вас в студії працюватиме Барбара Гальвеґ.
На все добре.
Доброго вечора.
До вашої уваги свіжий прогноз погоди.
Цього літа в Німеччині зафіксовано надзвичайно малу
кількість опадів.
З початку червня і до кінця серпня очікується
приблизно 103 л/кв. м.
Рекордно високу вологість було зафіксовано в 2018,
близько 130 л/кв. м.
Засуха не відступає.
Як і потужний східний антициклон.
А над Іспанією можемо спостерігати гарячий циклон.
Країна починає готуватися до наступної хвилі спеки.
Вночі сухо та вітряно на півдні,
температура в Альпах опуститься до 9°C,
а в регіоні Рейн-Майн - до 18°C.
Завтра буде традиційно сонячно, а
на півдні знову очікується сильний східний вітер,
який в гірських регіонах може
перерости в справжній буревій.
Тому ми зможемо
насолодитися приємною прохолодою.
На південному заході температура зросте до 32°C, на
заході - до 34°C, а на узбережжі Балтійського моря опуститься до 24°C.
Найближчими днями спека не відступатиме.
П'ятниця обіцяє грози,
температура досягатиме 34°C.
Субота та неділя видадуться посушливими,
температура досягатиме 35°C.
Гарного вечора. На все добре.